[Music]
this is Kilauea one of Hawaii's most
active volcanoes in 2018 interrupted and
destroyed around 700 homes and forced
thousands to evacuate
since then a lava lake that had been
boiling at the volcano summit has been
replaced with something exceedingly rare
water so how did all this happen and
what does this all mean for Hawaiians
living near the volcano to learn more we
spoke with a scientist at the USGS my
name is Don Swanson I'm a geologist with
the Hawaiian Volcano Observatory of the
US Geological Survey I'm retired but
I've been working on volcanoes for my
entire career so most of us have heard
of Kilauea
but maybe walk us through some basics
about the volcano and what has been
happening in the past month or so well
it was erupting almost continuously for
decades until last summer when a barrier
that had been keeping magma from getting
beyond that point failed somehow and so
magma was then able to travel down the
rift zone and the largest lava flow
during recorded history was erupted
farther away from the summit's
destroying more than 700 homes and
creating a lot of havoc the lava lake at
the summit which had been present for 10
years began to drop down great rapidly
and eventually the entire summit
collapsed the caldera collapsed up to
500 meters a little more and was quite
quiet until July 25th when we saw the
first visual change at the volcano in a
year and that was the appearance of this
green water pond in the bottom of the
crater and that's the interest that we
we have so do we have a good idea yet
whether this is water that is just kind
of rainfall sitting at the surface or
whether this is water that may be
bubbling up from deeper in the ground
that's a really good question and we
don't know the definite answer for that
yet but what we think it is is water
that is slowly infilling from below
rising up into the low part in the
crater there still remains the
possibility that it's a rainfall that is
directly feeding the pond but we don't
think that's true because the rate of
rise of the pond the rate of growth has
been pretty steady slow and steady now
since it was first recognized and that's
more consistent with slowly rising water
table than with rainfall so if it were
just water sitting on top from the rain
but perhaps more likely if it is
bubbling up from below how would the
implications be different for maybe
future eruptions of the volcano well if
there's just a puddle of water on the
surface then any future eruption
probably wouldn't be affected by the
water at all it would you know just be
so small but the problem comes in if the
water is deep much deeper than just on
that we can see but going down may be
several tens of meters into the hot
conduits that feeds magma then there are
two possibilities if magma rises very
slowly up through the water it's simply
going to evaporate the water and it RUP
does a lava flow and and that's that's
the kind of normal kind of eruption at
Kilauea but the problem comes in if the
magma is rising very rapidly like it's
starting one of these big fire fountains
that are so famous in Hawaii if the
magma is rising very rapidly already
starting to form a fountain and then it
encounters water then it transfers heat
to the water very quickly the water
boils generates steam which helps to
power the eruption and then we can have
a real explosion manufactured by both
the gas 'its
in the magma and the steam that's
derived from the
so in order to get an explosion like
that we need to have really sick water
body several tens of meters probably and
rapidly rising magma we're pretty sure
that such eruptions have happened in the
past we find evidence for that but we
don't think that they would be nearly as
large as some big boom you know this
that's going to affect people in distant
areas this would be something it would
likely be confined to the summit of the
volcano and only a portion of the summit
in fact so explosion possibility big
explosion probably not walk us through
what we're looking at here as far as the
geology is concerned and how that might
play into the way that this water is
forming this all has to do with the
level that the water table is at Kilauea
but low the water table rocks are
saturated with water because they're
quite permeable EF fractures running
through them we know from measurements
direct measurements that the water table
is at an elevation that's about 70
meters higher than the bottom of the
crater where the pond is starting to
form so there's quite a head there and
so we think that the water is it's
rising back up into the crater after
having been displaced during the
collapse last summer and theory this
level could continue to rise up another
70 meters or so to the level of the
water table that we've been measuring
whether we'll ever reach that height is
of course we don't know so there are
easier Sciences to do in this world then
studying volcanoes can you walk us
through how you go about studying the
volcano from here while still staying
safe we're able to remotely watch what's
happening from webcams that have been
installed on the rim of the caldera we
can also go to the rim and make visual
observations which we do on a daily
basis now and make make measurements to
the surface of the pond using a laser
rangefinder I take a lot of photographs
and videos and so forth and one of the
most important things that we can do now
is
sample of the water in that pond now
that isn't the easiest thing in the
world to do we're considering two
different options one dangling a bucket
from a long long line from a helicopter
or using a drone to get the sample but
if we even get a water sample then we
will be able to tell a lot about the
chemistry of the gases that is coming up
through the water and also we'll be able
to date the water and this can tell us
whether the water is coming from
groundwater as we think it is or if it's
coming directly from rainwater that's
falling into the crater so this is the
most important item on our agenda now
that we just hope that we can get
permission from the National Park to do
this sampling this is you know
fundamentally a different kind of
volcano than what you see more explosive
types like mount st. Helens the people
of Hawaii are not in danger of a
catastrophic explosion but there's
something unique going on here for the
last 2,500 years Kilauea has been in an
explosive mode more than half the time
believe it or not but we've been lulled
into thinking that it's just kind of a
docile volcano because the last 200
years since researchers have been here
it's been acting that way but at some
point in their future maybe the near
future it will return to an explosive
phase but these explosions are not in
general as large as a Mount st. Helens
or at other big explosive volcanoes
they're smaller because the magma is
less viscous fluid and
doesn't have as much gas in it and also
at Kilauea everything that's happening
is is deep in hole in the volcano and
large populations don't live right
adjacent to the summit of the volcano
where the explosions occur now there are
people living there don't get me wrong
her she was thousands of people there
but it's not like in Auckland New
Zealand or someplace where you can have
higher populations at risk and also the
wind here for big explosions the ash can
get up into the jet stream and the jet
stream typically blows toward the east
and the southeast which is very sparsely
populated part of the island so for all
those reasons although Kilauea erupts
frequently and in fact I've called
Kilauea an explosive volcano
it's explosions are not as large and
probably will not have as much impact on
society as with something like monsoon
happens how might this volcano what's
happening right now to the volcano
helped scientists figure out know more
about the specific volcano but also
apply those findings perhaps to other
volcanoes around the world the
generalization is always imperfect
because each volcano was a bit different
but we will watch the rate of rise of
the water in the crater and and that
will be something that's probably never
been done before what it sort of watched
the birth of a water lake in a caldera
from probably the groundwater not from
rainfall and and then if whatever
happens next regarding an eruption it
we'll be able to observe and evaluate
what impact if any of the water had on
that eruption and that will certainly be
a great interest to volcanoes around the
world that have water associated with
them even though comparatively little is
happening now at Kilauea it's still an
exceedingly exciting time to be at the
volcano because there's so much
uncertainty as to what might happen
following last summer's you
we really don't know how the volcano is
going to recover now if it's going to
return the way it was before last summer
and I think most people sort of assume
that's going to happen or is it going to
revert into a period of more explosive
activity like we know this has happened
in the past after there's been a caldera
collapse that's sort of my my feeling
are we going to return to the way it was
in the near past or are we going to
return to the way it was in the far past
that's the big question thank you very
much for joining us you're welcome